now that we've got a sense of our
critical questions and that they have
all been answered we need to consider
how many times they've been answered how
many users do we need to test with to
feel confident in our results luckily
for us it turns out that we really only
need a few people to get good data each
prototype should be shown to 325 users
in order to catch most of the issues in
the design one of the most fascinating
articles in user research by Jakob
Nielsen shows that on average a study of
three users will find upwards of sixty
percent of the issues with their
prototype a study of five users will
average upwards of seventy five percent
of the issues in either case that's
enough to get a sense of how the
prototype did and further research gives
vastly diminishing returns the art of
prototyping is not the art of extensive
QA it is a waste of time to find one
hundred percent of the issues in app
design that you plan on throwing app
when you have three to five users being
asked the same questions you start to
see trends user B will probably find
some of the same flaws as user a and
these flaws should be counted as more
glaring when you're thinking about how
to weigh data from various users it's
useful to go back to how critical the
question was if a critical part of the
app is going wrong from multiple users
you have a problem when you're thinking
about how to weigh data from various
users it's useful to go back to how
critical a question was if a critical
part of the app is going wrong from
multiple users you have a problem if a
less critical part of the app is going
wrong for multiple users you're probably
still fine and can iron that out in
medium fidelity prototypes so for our
app will want to bucket the feedback
from all of our users into some style of
yes or no by question that will allow us
to actually make a decision about our
appt moving forward you'll note that
we've only done research with two users
for our study that's because when we
include your user testing will have a
full study of three users in the next
node will decide whether to make another
loaf I prototype or whether to move on
to a medium fidelity one